thank you um it's my honor to be here  and thanks to the Academy for everything  that has happened in this week it means  a lot to me and Congress the other  winners and it was pleasure to meet you  guys you guys are so talented filmmakers  and I like to thanks to everyone who  giving me help and support thanks to my  father and mother and families and  friends who helped me when I stressed  out and thanks to you know thanks to the  people from Scrubs art a John Mackey  jump back and lower knowledge special  thanks to my supervisor Harry Darlington  and thanks to my classmate for giving me  our feedbacks and critics without you  guys I'm come on is not possible to be  here tonight then thank you